and then apply my usual networking
strategies so this is the main area
where the presentations will be given
Lee oh man wish you the best of luck so
pump to see where you go I want to see
you win so badly and I know you're gonna
crush it
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up believe nation happy day five
of my spring trip adventure to
Philadelphia in Palm Springs
it is Wednesday for me in his Palm
Springs day I arrived last night slept
not that great was up for 23 straight
hours but look at this view that view
oh good cow I woke up in at 4:00 in the
morning because it's actually seven in
the morning kind of time and ended up
sleeping in a little bit Justine in bed
until five something got a chance to
talk with Nina which is awesome because
I missed her last night and the day kind
of starts at 8:00 what time is it now
6:49 day starts at 8:00 and that's
breakfast and then events meetings
meetings maybes meeting session session
session sessions vlogging with Leo and
we'll see where the day goes I'm excited
I'm have more energy than I thought it
would
we'll see how long the day goes but
meeting entrepreneurs and being around
it just gives me so much energy so I'm
pumped for another great day let's see
what the today takes us
[Music]
7:30 breakfast starts at 8:00 I'm gonna
go hang out I'm gonna be there early and
then apply my usual networking
strategies of sit in the middle of the
room with my t-shirt on pull up my phone
and start doing DMS reply to people get
the energy going and attract people to
me you want to have a conversation I
know some of the people are ready in
there but I'm gonna meet some good
people probably too and that's my best
networking strategy set the middle of
room dry fire through IG Twitter
snapchat DMS and then people come to me
and want to strike up a conversation I'm
not the natural go talk to people
introduce myself so that's how I win you
got to understand yourself and build
strategies around it
so this is the main area where the
presentations will be given that's the
main stage I think I'm on there tomorrow
and I love getting here early I'm the
first one as you can see but I get here
early because I can get my spot here
because I can get that sweet goodness I
got to get the plug got to get the power
so I can be on my laptop the whole day
charged ready to go answering emails
taking notes spreading value this is a
nice space way bigger than last year
this is gonna be me tomorrow
[Music]
it's a little bit of good news bad news
Leo who you guys saw in the last vlog
after our intense day together decided
that he doesn't want to be a
videographer anymore and me pushing him
to sing in Crete songs and post on
social media that he's been avoiding for
the past X number of months eight nine
months like that me pushing him to do it
on the spot inspired him to understand
that he wants to be in front of the
camera and he wants to believe in
himself more and spread to his mission
and message and he doesn't want to be
behind the camera anymore so he's he
messaged me this morning thanking me for
the opportunity and he was gonna
withdraw his application to be my
videographer and you know on the small
scale I'm I'm sad because I love Leo the
dude is amazing and was really looking
forward to what we could co-create
together but on a bigger scale I'm just
so pumped and happy for him I told him
he should still come down drive over
here you're gonna learn a lot from the
event and I just want to see you win man
I want to see you win so we'll see if he
comes but otherwise I hope you're
cheering Leo on as well and it just
makes me happy you know when people
doing the thing they should be doing
even at my own I pushed him away right
to my own expense but him winning is the
ultimate and it's the same thing for
anybody on your team you'll find that
people are with you for a certain amount
of time you run in parallel paths and as
long as you're running parallel paws
together it's your job to help them grow
help them learn help them understand you
know what they want at a life and if you
can provide it great and if you can't
then you need to push them away you need
to let them do the thing you need to
encourage them and believe in them even
to your own detriment in the short term
because long term it always pays off
long term it always pays off thing with
Leo long term is gonna pay off but it
doesn't even matter because it's the
right thing to do doing the right thing
is always the right thing so Leo men
wishing the best of luck so pumped to
see where you go I want to see you win
so badly and I know you're gonna crush
it man
so I'm gonna head back in and bettan
hasn't started yet I got my seat I'm
gonna do some quick emails and catch up
on some of the work that I missed and
then start the first session with a win
video this is the guy I was talking
about own video hardest work in the
business non-stop adding value shaking
it up bringing the entertainment value
Owens up first I got my table right here
got my plug front-row seat ready to see
this man crush it talking what are we
talking a male list I love it I'm I'm
here to learn I'm here to learn wait
first sesh with on video next up mister
Derral Eve's gonna do some knowledge
transfer and updates they need to
algorithm super pump to get my front-row
seat
so Leo came back I ended off saying I
was kind of talking about your Facebook
message I didn't know if you were gonna
come back or not today so I decided to
come back he's filming for the rest of
the day tell us tell us where you're at
Leo inspired past couple months I've
been really as Tim with going back on
social media because my life it's care
about the weight gainer pad and then
what evident based leave was challenging
me to post a video and a selfie
immediately now everybody knows on
believe nation about Leos winky - this
is great I love it this is fantastic
life-changing okay we're gonna hop in -
Jeremy best good friend of mine from vid
IQ he's doing an event on analytics that
we're gonna check out alright main
sessions done we're feeling the heat
Leo's losing the sweater losing a
sweater we're gonna go back to the hotel
room after a full day and now film
videos for you guys I got a whole bunch
of videos to film but I normally do in a
day full day got a crunch down Sam and I
can get done for you so that you guys
have some content to enjoy pumping out
three meters a day take some effort
Leo's about to see how it gets done back
to the room okay we got distracted and
did a whole bunch of chatting and
vlogging and didn't film anything yet so
we're gonna go find a good location this
Leo guy asked great questions and it's
just a good human being so forget we get
into these long discussions that
hopefully lead to quality content if not
I'm going to be really pissed off yeah
[Laughter]
one Life OK we've already changed your
life leo we need we need to change more
lives than just Leo don't be so selfish
man that's it selfish Leo calm we're
gonna we're gonna buy some medical we're
gonna friend us about the film so we can
make the content for you
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
we just finished filling we got some
more feeling to do but we got some
business strats to discuss as we go eat
some in-and-out burger we're kickin up
the health factor here in California
I've never been in an out burger so
we're gonna somebody recommended it when
we checked in oh no you did Lia
recommended it yes so we're gonna go get
some in-n-out burger I ever had a
hamburger in like a year I think I've
had three hamburgers in three days so I
liked it let's try in that time
[Music]
all right just past ten quarter past ten
had some great combo with with Leo the
convo with Lee oh I'm gonna go back to
the hotel film a couple videos probably
go until about midnight
my throat's itchy from talking so much
but we still got some content to make
then pass out wake up tomorrow another
day another day another day have a great
night hope you have a fantastic night
thank you for another amazing journey
will take you one more day here in Palm
Springs and then I get to go home and
see the wife pump for that I'm very
grateful that I got a chance to talk to
her quickly before she went to bed
living three hours in the past out here
on the west coast is a little rough on
the schedule to connect so I'm grateful
for that
thank you guys I hope you had a great
weekend continue to believe and whatever
your one word is much love see soon